hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big analysis guys on the
s p 500 i'm going to use the spy ticker
which is the tracker of the s p 500 and
we're gonna here make a long term
analysis and the short-term analysis and
you're gonna see that we have some
bearish signals that are coming and that
when they came in the past they were
always almost followed by correction so
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so let's start maybe quickly
guys on the weekly time frame because
this is the very long term move that we
are doing actually since the 208 crisis
when we started to ease the measures for
the fiscal policies and for the economy
when there were massive injections of
free money in the market which started
this huge move up and we are still in
this move up so the way i see things
guys is first wave here then corrective
wave in 411 then we got our massive
third wave that lasts until 2 or 18 then
i see the huge coveted crisis as the end
of an expanding triangle guys which is a
very rare pattern actually force waves
they usually like to be triangles but
they're usually converging triangles not
expanding and here we have a beautiful
example of an expanding triangle so you
can see here the market is making high
highs and here it's making lower lows so
we are in this type of pattern and then
in 202 21 we had the upside breakout of
this huge expanding triangle which is
called as well the megaphone pattern
because of the shape it has and since
then we are very bullish so let's
analyze now the move that started here
guys because this is our fifth wave okay
our major fifth wave and it's definitely
not complete
so i think there is a lot of upside to
come for the coming years but we are
having inside this fixed wave as usual
five waves so let's go on a daily
timeframe and let's analyze the
situation here guys so the first rebound
that happened just after the crisis was
very impulsive very strong it's
definitely our first wave so one two
three four five
so this would be
first wave here
then you can see guys we had a flat
correction here a b c and you guys know
that when we have a flat in the second
wave usually we have a zigzag in the
force wave so here for me this is the
signal that the third wave this one so
this whole move up is complete one two
three four five and the fifth wave is
contained in a wedge pattern and forming
a bearish divergence so the burst
divergence comes from here you can see
the market is making higher highs and
the momentum indicator is making lower
highs so this means the market is out of
steam and you can notice that each time
the s p 500 corrected we had the signal
you can see here in 2020 just before the
crisis market making new highs but the
macd was going lower and you know what
followed just after that and even inside
this whole move up you can see that for
example here we had as well this bearish
divergence here is the only time where
the correction was not very deep we have
here market making new highs and just a
small correction but still there was one
month correction that followed after
this breakout happened so here we are at
the very early stage of this false
corrective wave so to me
as we are still in this fifth wave i
think that the upper band of our
megaphone pattern should act as support
so this purple turn lander is here
so depending how fast we go
but we have some strong supports here so
the first one is this one i don't think
it's going to hold guys because here we
have this gap down that is ugly so it's
not looking good at all so this would
probably not hold and i expect the
second one to hold at 400 roughly 403
so this is roughly the area where we see
the s p 500 going in the coming month so
maybe we're gonna as usual by the deep
and then start to move lower all right
so this is a possible scenario it is my
preferred scenario for now so once again
what we are playing here is the
completion of this third wave in yellow
one two three four five we have our
wedge pattern that is here we have the
bearish divergence that was starting
already two months ago but once again
those divergences are good to play once
we have the breakout so here we have the
divergence the breakout and the
completion of the third wave so we have
everything that is telling us that this
should correct
around maybe one month so this is our
view for the coming month and then of
course a strong rebound and we're gonna
complete this fifth wave that might go
as high as like a 500 600 for the spy
something like this so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i see you guys